I hope you're all still having a good
day I we're going to begin this plenary
which will be in three parts first with
the announcement of some commitments I'd
like to begin by asking
Susan Arnold a vice chairman of Procter
& Gamble to come up here their
commitment is that Procter & Gamble will
partner with the children's safe
drinking partners and 20 other
organizations to provide clean drinking
water to reduce severe diarrhea and
childhood death in 13 nations in Africa
Asia and the Caribbean in addition
working with UNICEF through its Pampers
brand P&G will contribute to the
elimination of maternal and neonatal
tetanus by supporting UNICEF procurement
of close to 45 million tetanus vaccines
this is worth about 20 million dollars
over five years for safe drinking water
another two million for the tetanus
vaccine commitment I just like to remind
those of you who were here last year
that at last year's meeting P&G
partnered with others to provide safe
drinking water and hygiene education to
a million children in Africa 135 million
litres of safe drinking water from PU
our practices by two packets by 2009 and
to date in keeping their last year's
commitment they have already reached
200,000 children and they're actually on
track to exceed these goals now building
on that commitment P&G and their partner
organizations are going to provide an
additional 2 billion litres of safe
drinking water by 2012 it will save an
excellent an estimated 10,000 lives and
this tetanus initiative will procure 45
million tetanus vaccines for use in
developing countries each package of
Pampers will cover the cost of one shot
surfer so for those of you still of an
age and a family circumstance
I urge you to go support this thank you
so much Susan let's give her a big hand
thank you very very much
now I'd like to invite to the stage
Betsy Tyler the chair of one sky Steven
Heinz the president of the Rockefeller
Brothers fund Jesse Fink the managing
director of Mission Point Capital
Partners they have another partner the
Ella Baker Center for Human Rights I
don't know if they're President Van
Jones is here but if he is I hope he'll
come up you did great on that Kosovo
thanks their commitment is to bring
together a broad range of corporate and
nonprofit partners to develop a national
call for action on climate change it is
valued at fifty million dollars and
here's how it will work one sky will
lead a broad coalition to develop and
push the United States government to
deliver sweeping climate change
solutions they will execute a
communications and field campaign with
the objective of convincing the United
States to match the European Union
commitments on climate change in March
of 2007 the European Union agreed to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions by 20%
below 1990 levels to increase the use of
renewable energy to 20% of all energy
consumed to increase energy efficiency
by 20%
you may remember on the morning panel
when we when Vice President Gore was
here we were discussing this I believe I
said and if I didn't I'm most safe for
the first time we had a young man I know
who works for Goldman Sachs gave me a
study that the company had commissioned
which said if the United States simply
reaches the energy efficiency levels of
Japan and China India and Russia do the
same we will reduce greenhouse gas
emissions globally by 20% this is a big
deal for all of us to be pursuing the
same goal and a particularly sense we
have now an enormous amount of energy
in the American investment community in
getting all major carbon emitters to
report their carbon footprint Merrill
Lynch is leading the effort in America
this year but investors with total
portfolios of 41 trillion dollars are
now involved in this and all the may of
the major European countries companies
75% are participating 60% of the
American companies up to 40 set up from
47% last year so we actually have the
chance to get this done and that's why
this commitment is so important I think
all of you know that 2006 was the
hottest year on record in the United
States in case you were paying attention
I know when I got out of the airplane
yesterday afternoon coming back from the
50th anniversary of the Little Rock
Central High School crisis in my home
state and I landed at Westchester
Airport in the early evening it was six
degrees warmer than it had been at noon
that day and we were reaching another
historically warm week here we've got a
lot of states doing what they should do
we've got a lot of interest in the
federal government and increased R&D but
we don't have a national goal and we
don't have a real policy to try to bring
us into alignment in the results we
achieve so I am personally very very
grateful to once guy to the Rockefeller
Brothers fund to Mission Point Capital
Partners to Jonathan rose companies in
the Ella Baker Center for Human Rights
and I would like to present this
commitment to them and thank them and
ask you to give them a hand
really
now this next commitment in my view
alone justifies the decision we made
this year to have a separate track on
education and of course this plenary
will involve a fascinating discussion of
Education ideas after we do phase two
that's phase three so this is the last
commitment I'm going to announce in my
view this is something that demonstrates
as well as anything else CGI will do
this year what this conference is about
about getting people together and
leveraging our various resources and
strengths to really change lives in 2006
Angelina Jolie and my former national
economic adviser Gene Sperling who now
runs the Center for universal education
at the Council on Foreign Relations
agreed to co-chair a new Education
Partnership for children of conflict the
partnerships goal is to help fund new
education projects for children and
conflict post-conflict refugee and
emergency situations which will be
announced every year here at CGI their
first year has had an inspiring start 18
commitments in places from Iraq to
Colombia to northern Uganda to
Afghanistan to Darfur there's no doubt
that by expanding and improving access
to education we can have a profound
impact on some of the world's most
vulnerable children this is a commitment
that showcases perfectly the commitment
of this meeting to getting results and
not just talking about problems I'd like
to give you an idea of the scope and
impact of these 18 projects and how they
help fund new education projects for
children and conflict post-conflict
refugee and emergency situations and
this cost a hundred and fifty million
dollars consider that combined impact of
these investments specifically Li UNICEF
along with Microsoft the International
Rescue Committee and Hewlett Packard
well launch a 30 million-dollar distance
learning initiative to help a hundred
and fifty thousand children including
children from the Iraq conflict and
children in the occupied Palestinian
territories the International Rescue
Committee is expanding its healing
classrooms initiative to help 70
thousand children in Afghanistan and
41,000 affected by Darfur Save the
Children Alliance will expand education
programs in places like Jordan and
Lebanon to serve Iraqi refugees and in
Darfur and Southern Sudan the Sesame
Workshop is committed to launch Sesame
Street Afghanistan you guys are supposed
to come up here as I managed to mention
your group's Sesame Street Afghanistan
to teach Afghan children not only to
read but to understand words like
tolerance and reconciliation the
American Jewish World Service is
committed to raise over two million
dollars to support education in Darfur
Sri Lanka Burma and Guatemala the
Norwegian Refugee Council will expand
its accelerated learning programs to
serve over 100,000 out-of-school youth
in southern Sudan and Iraqi refugees in
Lebanon and Syria the children's
investment fund foundation is committed
an additional three million dollars to
expand the International Rescue
Committee education work in northern
Uganda unbound philanthropy is committed
to fund a half a million dollars in
projects developed through the
partnership the escuela nueva foundation
will spread its philosophy of holistic
child centered education to nearly nine
thousand children in conflict affected
areas of Colombia the Center for
mind-body medicine will provide
psychological counseling and support to
25 thousand school children traumatized
by the conflict in Gaza
to allow them to learn effectively in
the classroom the GSM Association is
working with the United Nations
Commissioner for Human Rights or
refugees to bring wireless connectivity
to help train teachers and improve
learning in northern Uganda the High
Commissioner for Refugees in partnering
with Nike Microsoft WPP and others is
using the Global Initiative to relaunch
9 million org a grassroots internet
portal designed to help provide
education in sports to all refugees
children the Valentino dong foundation
has committed 1.2 million to build a
boarding school in southern Sudan and he
is here and the hero of Dave Eggers
Eggers magnificent book what is what so
I want to particularly represent a
recognized mr. down here give him a hand
thank you
we have up here on this state's
representatives of every group I have
mentioned and I now like to invite the
co-chairs of the Education Partnership
for children this conflict gene sperling
and Angelina Jolie here let me remind
you as they come up to receive this
certificate these people have really
done a lot but remember the title of the
website there are nine million displaced
children who cannot go to school because
of things that happen to them and their
families that work completely beyond
their control so if any of you want to
do something good and you came here and
hadn't decided what to support look at
this you know you've got a network here
of people who will get a very high rate
of return at a high rate of efficiency
and we've got still a breathtaking
number of children to reach but in the
meanwhile let's give them all a hand for
doing something profoundly good
now before we do our plenary we're going
to hear a brief address from a person
I'm very glad to welcome here the
Minister of Foreign Affairs of China
yung Tucci he wanted to be here this
morning when we were discussing climate
change no nation has a bigger stake in
trying to deal with this in a way that
does not interrupt its economic progress
and I personally have enjoyed working
with the Minister of Foreign Affairs and
with the Chinese Ministry of Health
because our foundation runs a major AIDS
project there all over the country and
it's been incredibly rewarding before he
became the Minister of Foreign Affairs
foreign minister Yong was Vice Minister
of Foreign Affairs and before that he
was the ambassador of China to the
United States from 2001 to 2005 I think
he waited until I left because he was
afraid I would talk his ear off we are
deeply honored to have him here I am
particularly grateful for the work that
he has done to try to help resolve a
very difficult crisis with regard to
North Korea and the nuclear issue and
for the receptivity that he has had
trying to change United Nations policy
on Darfur to make it more effective and
save lives and of course because of the
support of the government of China we
are able to save a lot of lives from HIV
and AIDS I've rarely seen a country
change its position so rapidly and so
effectively to the benefit of its
children so foreign minister young
please come up and ladies and gentlemen
please welcome the Foreign Minister of
China
President Clinton ladies and gentlemen
dear friends it's a great pleasure for
me to attend the 2007 annual meeting of
the Clinton Global Initiative at the
invitation of President Clinton
President Clinton has in recent years
made admirable efforts to promote
international cooperation on poverty
alleviation disaster relief and the
prevention and treatment of hiv/aids the
Clinton Global Initiative sponsored by
President Clinton addresses many issues
including sustainable development
poverty alleviation health education and
climate change and is important in
boosting international cooperation in
resolving these global issues that
concern the interests of all countries I
greatly appreciate this initiative taken
by President Clinton here I will add to
speak on the topic of economic
development and climate change by the
way this time I've come for the UN
General Assembly session and climate
change features prominently during the
session and I'm very glad to have this
opportunity to be in your midst and
thank you for giving me the stage ladies
and gentlemen we live in an age of
deepening economic globalization
increasing scientific and technological
innovations an unprecedented opportunity
for human development on the other hand
Global Economic Development is
confronted with many challenges
particularly mounting pressure on
energy and resources an acute ecological
degradation global warming rising sea
level extreme weather and the
weather-related natural disasters caused
by climate change are adversely
affecting the natural ecological system
and a human habitat climate change has
become a pressing challenge for the
international community a review of
history shows that climate change
occurred in the cause of development it
is both an environment issue and the
development issue but ultimately it is a
development issue as pointed out in the
United Nations Framework Convention on
Climate Change most of historical and
current global emissions of greenhouse
gases originated in developed countries
were per capita emissions in developing
countries are still relatively low the
share of global emissions originating in
developing countries will grow as they
work to meet their social and
development needs to prevent climate
change from endangering human survival
and development while maintaining
economic development a meeting the
legitimate demand of the people this is
an issue that concerns the well-being
and the future of all mankind economic
development and environmental protection
and efforts to tackle climate change
should be mutually reinforcing rather
than mutually conflicting for developing
countries like China whose level of
economic development is still low and
whose people are yet to live a better
life the most pressing issue for them is
to grow the economy erase people's
living standards efforts to tackle
climate change should promote economic
development and not be pursued at the
expense
the economic development on the other
hand we must not fail to see that an
economic development model of high
energy consumption high pollution and
high emissions is not sustainable and
the path of pursuing development first
in treating pollution next is not a
viable one the bursty Environment Policy
is also the best economic policy
countries should all incorporate thank
you thank you countries should all
incorporate environmental protection
into their overall economic development
strategies and take resolute measures to
follow a path of sustainable development
this way enables us to address
environment issues through economic
development and promote economic
development by resolving environment
issues thus ensuring both economic
development and the environmental
protection ladies and gentlemen
China will remain the largest developing
country for a long time to come and
there are imbalances between urban and
rural areas in different regions and
between economic and social development
its per capita GDP is behind the 100th
place globally and there are still over
20 million poor rural people and more
than 22 million urban residents receive
basic living allowances China is faced
with the daunting task of growing its
economy and eliminating poverty the
Chinese government with the strong sense
of responsibility to the Chinese people
in people of the world takes climate
change seriously and has taken concrete
measures to tackle it at the APEC
economic leaders meeting in sit
early this month president who Jintao
reaffirmed China's position on climate
change and spoke on the forceful
measures it has adopted in addressing
climate change a national leading group
on climate change headed by Premier Wen
Jiabao has been set up in China has
promulgated a series of related laws and
regulations it released the National
Programme on climate change in June the
first developing country to do so China
has contributed chair to reducing global
greenhouse gas emissions by carrying out
a series of policy measures including
economic adjustment improving the energy
mix raising energy efficiency and a
forestation statistics show that by
raising energy efficiency alone China
saved 800 million tons of standard coal
from 1991 to 2005 and the equivalent of
reducing 1.8 billion tons of co2 China
has set the targets of reducing energy
intensity by 20%
reducing discharge of major pollutants
by 10% and increasing forest cover from
eighteen point two percent to 20 percent
for the period between the end of 2005
and 2010 all these steps show the
Chinese government's commitment to
tackling climate change the Chinese
government pursues sustainable
development as a national strategy and
the Environmental Protection as a basic
national policy it believes that
environmental problems should be
resolved through development and is
actively exploring ways to ensure
coordinated environmental protection and
economic development China is fully
implemented
what we call the scientific thinking on
development which puts people first and
aims at promoting comprehensive balanced
and a sustainable development we are
endeavoring to transform the inefficient
economic growth model and we are working
to ensure balance between economic
development and population resources in
the pursuit of harmony between man and
nature China is pursuing an eco-friendly
development path to achieve economic
development make life better for its
people and protect the environment we
are committed to controlling greenhouse
gas emissions and strengthening our
capacity to adapt to climate change so
as to play a constructive role in
tackling climate change ladies and
gentlemen as the impact of climate
change is global in nature and concerns
the interests of all countries this
issue can only be addressed through
extensive international cooperation
developed countries should face up to
their historical responsibilities and
the reality of their high per capita
emissions they should follow the
principle of common but differentiated
responsibilities which is embodied in
the UN Framework Convention on Climate
Change and the Kyoto Protocol and take
the lead in emission reduction they
should help developing countries improve
their capacity to tackle climate change
and take the path of sustainable
development by providing financial
resistance transferring technologies and
assisting them in capacity-building
and adapting to climate change
developing countries on their part
should take measures in light of their
conditions give high priority to
introducing advanced clean technologies
make that you contribution to tackling
climate change the Chinese government
will as always promote and participate
the international cooperation on climate
change it will continue to take an
active part in the negotiations on
environmental conventions concerning
climate change in a biodiversity and on
trade and environment it will promote
international cooperation on Clean
Development Mechanism and technology
transfer take part in other cooperation
mechanisms such as the Asia Pacific
Partnership
and Clean Development and the climate
and support they're supplementary ro
China will continue to make unremitting
efforts to tackle climate change not
long ago the leading group was set up in
the Chinese foreign ministry to provide
guidance to China's diplomatic efforts
to address climate change as China's
foreign minister I'm the head of this
group we have also appointed a special
representative for negotiations on
climate change this once again shows the
Chinese government's commitment to
participating in international
cooperation in addressing climate change
ladies and gentlemen peace and
development are the core of our times we
should respect history address current
problems the future or entity and carry
out cooperation in good faith by doing
so we can certainly strike a balance
between promoting economic development
and tackling climate change and realize
the harmonious coexistence between man
and nature thank you
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen please welcome our
panelists the President of the Republic
of Colombia Alvaro Uribe founder of the
Valentino attack gang foundation
Valentino a check dong Minister of
Education for the Islamic Republic of
Afghanistan Mohammed Hanif Emir up our
co-chair of the jolie-pitt foundation
Angelina Jolie a ladies and gentlemen
please welcome our moderator New York
Times columnist Nicholas Kristof thank
you very much we have a just a terrific
panel on an issue that could not be more
important or where you don't get more
bang for the buck and I might say also
that it's shaping up as a more
auspicious occasion than the last time I
spoke in proximity with President
Clinton I was giving the commencement
address at the Kennedy School of
Government at Harvard and right at the
same time on the same day it turned out
a hundred yards away who should be
scheduled to speak
President Clinton so as I walk in I see
these crowds walking in the other
direction and I had taken my daughter
out of school and my 9 year old daughter
and I didn't want her see your father
totally humiliated so I said you know
Caroline you should be prepared
you're you may be the only person in the
entire audience because President
Clinton is speaking right across the
street and you know what she said
she looked up at me and thought for a
moment and said daddy can I go hear
President Clinton
so I just want to clarify President
Clinton will not be speaking across the
street okay now we have just an
incredible panel with extraordinary
knowledge about the situation in
conflict zones in education around the
world president of our eBay of Columbia
and Columbia is important because it has
a number of ventures in rural education
under way and indeed some of those with
the help of some NGOs that are
represented here and then Valentino
attack Deng for those of you who haven't
read it the book what is the what is the
story of Valentino's just extraordinary
life from Southern Sudan to here and
it's it's an amazing saga an amazing
book in a testament to how important
education is and he is now building a
school back in Sudan Mohammad Honeycutt
more from Afghanistan the Education
Minister of Afghanistan you think you
know that's an extraordinarily tough job
will previously under the Taliban he was
working for various NGOs and education
issues that was pretty tough and then
Angelina Jolie best known for her work
as an advocate of refugees
oh come on Angelina has done
extraordinary she may not be best known
for it but she has done extraordinary
work traveling around tirelessly to some
really forgotten places in the world
from really you know rural places in
Cambodia to Darfur more times than I
believe all the secretaries General of
the UN put together and has been very
active
very active on these issues so let me
start president uribe there are so many
issues out there in needed in terms of
fighting poverty and we've been exposed
to them with the health issue all kinds
of issues why is education so important
for development and I mean in fact I
think the reason it tends to get
neglected is because it's seen as not so
urgent
not a life-and-death matter on any one
day so why should we be giving this
focus on education Thank You moderator
president clinton distinguished
panelists ladies and gentlemen thank you
all for inviting me it is a great honor
and thank you and president clinton for
this excellent initiative in colombia we
have three main objectives in our
administration to consolidate Makati
security to consolidate investment
confidence and to fulfill our social
goals education is the first in the list
of our social goals why because to
sustain democracy people need to know
the democracy give people the
opportunity to ascend in the social
ladder and a way for the people to her
mobility to ascend the social ladder is
education in addition to that education
creates opportunities for more
productivity more competitiveness more
income and better distinguishing of ink
we have problems and we have challenges
and tools one big problem we cannot meet
is that illicit drugs in my country is
an obstacle for people to have all the
opportunities of education
we have a many challenges in our country
one is to get for the year 2010 full
coverage in basic education now we have
93 daughter is to begin with infant
education for people under five we are
only beginning for vulnerable people the
other is to get 6 million Colombians in
vocational training in presidential and
beautiful schemes the other is to get
very poor coverage 34% of coverage in
university education the other is to
provide 46,000 people who have
demobilize from the tourist groups to
provide them with basic education with
university portunities who attend jobs
with vocational training the other is to
provide 600,000 displays juvenile people
with education we have tools I will
mention you with a list of some tools
and later on you you can choose which
told us to me about ok one to listen
built on education order to list
families in action introduced by my
predecessor president Pastrana other to
lase new school whose creator is here
with us Vicki Colvin
this very important rule other to least
to expand the estate agency for children
warfare to be be to be able to provide
food to 12 million children now we have
gotten 9 million other to list to
provide students without
from vocational training with
microlending with one system would call
bank of opportunities when you provide
the families with micro lending the
family gets tranquility and the
children's attend the school these are
some of the ends and some of the tools
thank you
hasn't every day Minister add more
Minister autumn are one of my heroes is
Mukhtar am I in Pakistan who used the
compensation money after she had been
gang raped to start schools in her area
because she thought that the best way to
fight extremism and fundamentalism and
the values that had led to her rate were
precisely to educate people
I wondered if in the context of
Afghanistan and somebody who was there
during the period of the Taliban to what
extent is education a force for fighting
I guess what I'm asking is can schools
be as effective in fighting extremism as
gunships for example well first let me
take this opportunity to thank President
Clinton and the organizers for inviting
us second before I answer your question
let me tell you about something that is
very important for us these days in
Afghanistan to see how much our women
and men alive value education and why
they are doing bad unfortunately over
the past 14 months that I am the
Minister of Education a hundred and
fifteen of my teachers and students have
been brutally killed by the terrorists
forty percent of them women in June this
year unfortunately one of the worst
incidents in my life happened and when
the terrorists attacked one of our girls
schools in Logar actually your paper
covered that story
and after three hours I went to the
school to see the injured girls actually
two girls were shot dead their teacher
and three other girls were badly injured
so I went to see one of the injured
girls in the hospital it was a clinic
rather than a hospital I couldn't stop
my tears so I engaged her another
discussion and said look my child I'll
take care of of your treatment she said
I'm not worried about that what I'm
worried about
she turned to me and said Uncle minister
about our school make sure that our
school doesn't get close and that was
the time I made one of my biggest
commitments in life and I said my child
whatever I have in my power I would make
sure that your school doesn't get closed
and I think there had been schools
earlier then do you think that you know
if if those men who committed those
attacks if they had gone to school would
such attacks have been less likely of
course the school was protected by the
communities this is one of our key
policies that we are trying to actually
give that responsibility to the parents
and the communities we say to them if
you wanted education for your kids it's
your responsibility to protect them and
we as the government will do everything
to support you and it's not just
protection for your school we want you
to manage your schools we want a new
governance system in our education that
is people let parents lead system I mean
the question we need to ask is why are
Afghan women and men value in education
to this extent that they are even taking
that kind of risk
to send their kids to schools despite
the forces of terrorism and what they do
so brutally and still there are these
courageous people men and women who are
sending their kids there are four key
words that I have often heard from from
them education is important for survival
education is important for peace it
brings peace education is important for
prosperity education is important for
having a voice in the system it's
important in terms of survival that the
kids of an educated mother have better
chances of survival with women trained
and educated you can deliver the most
crucial services public goods health and
education it's important in terms of
peace because they think that the
children of an educated woman will be
less susceptible to the manipulation by
the warlord
and the terrorists that educated men
will have other opportunities rather
than serving the terrorists it's
important in terms of having a voice in
the system yes Afghanistan is beginning
to become a Democratic Society but
educated women will be able to have a
better voice in in that system and it's
important in terms of prosperity that
there's no capital more strategic than
human capital for freedom from poverty
and that's exactly is their
understanding and therefore it's so much
valuable for them to make sure that
their kids are educated in an Gian in
that context of Education as a force for
stability you've just returned from Iraq
and Syria and you were looking at Iraqi
refugee area Araki refugee issues
there's concern about the creation of a
new large diaspora that is not getting
adequately educated that may be a force
for instability what what did you see
can you give us a little sense of those
unfulfilled education needs in that
community
sure well first I'd like to say in all
you know you know in all situations it's
it's it's kind of a strange thing when I
was preparing for this I I kind of
thought what are we all going to say how
what can I say what can you say what can
we all say to encourage everybody to
understand that education is important
it seems such a unnecessary thing to do
everybody in this room is very educated
and everybody knows the value of what
we're talking about it children in
conflict and refugee children because
they have lost everything they have
nothing and they have been traumatized
and they have been hurt and they have
witnessed more than we pray our children
ever have to see and all they have left
is their minds all they have left is a
possible future and what are they going
to do and what are they going to be and
if they are and they are susceptible to
so much and they're feeling so
much and if we can take these young
people who are such great young people
and their survivors and their kids and
give them amazing opportunities and say
we're gonna help show you how to learn
about reconciliation we're going to
teach you about what it is to be a
teacher a lawyer and engineer and we're
gonna we're going to instill in you the
the knowledge of how to then build your
country and have a future and it's not
just that we want them to be these
things we don't want them to be other
things we don't want them to grow up and
not have anything to live for and not
feel that they're of any use and not
know what to do and then they are
subject to anything and there are many
many schools of people that do encourage
very bad behavior that will offer a free
lunch and an education and it is
something we should be concerned about
and we don't want them to turn to those
schools so when I was there there are
there are many many children at a school
and those who are in school in Syria
there are three to a desk but there very
few of them they're able to get into any
school and if I had do I have a moment
to tell us more story or you want to get
sure yeah just just as the the type of
the picture of the child that we're
talking about from me I met I met two
men I met a young man who had been for
religious reasons he had been tortured
for three days he had been set on fire
and thrown in the garbage he was very
very badly burned and infected he was
begging on the streets he tried to get
into one country he couldn't he was
attempted to get some medical aid and
squads came in to kill everybody so he
had to leave he begged his way into
Syria and he was still living as a
beggar on the streets and and his burns
are becoming increasingly more infected
ran into a little boy who's also a
refugee who's selling tissues because
they don't have camps they have to make
a living they get some kind of
assistance from UNHCR but that's how
refugees are living in Syria so he's
selling sick tissues and this little boy
ended up giving this man a little bit of
water and then he said could you help me
I'll give you some of my begging money
but I need I need to somebody to help me
fix my wounds
and this kid was scared and weeks went
on in the end the kid agreed to do it
and they first did it they unwrapped
these wounds and forgive me
they're covered in maggots and this
little boy got scared and he ran and the
man said he came back he came back not
just for the money can't he came back
because he was a good kid
when I met them they'd been together for
about four months this kid had been
treating this man helping him cleaning
out his wounds wrapping him every day
stop giving him money just did it
because they were friends and he
continued every day to sell tissues on
the street so I said to this little boy
he was about eight I said you know you'd
be the most amazing doctor one day you
you're you're quite extraordinary and
and I watched him undo the bandages and
do all these things and I said would you
would you like to be a doctor and he got
real upset and he just said no I I have
to sell tissues and I said I'm so sorry
but you know we could find a way would
you like to be doctors yes ma'am but I
need to sell tissues so that's the kind
of kid were talking about he's an
amazing he's an amazing force for good
and he's he would be the doctor I'd want
but he's the type of kid that they're
not just begging and they're not just
sitting there with nothing to do and
they don't want to get involved in bad
activity they they're great young people
and we need to help them be doctors
well people like that unfortunately are
falling through the cracks all over the
world especially in conflict areas but
one who against all odds did not fall
through is valentino and I believe that
that is in part through a refugee
schooling program funded in part by Save
the Children and UNHCR and so if any of
you have ever contributed to those
groups then you can feel some pride in
in Valentino's extraordinary success
here Valentino could you talk a little
bit about your own unbelievable
journey and the role that education give
us a window of how education helped
shape that journey and have led you to
be right here tonight I'm from South
Sudan and I was born in 1980 two years
after my birth a civil war broke out in
my country that was fought between the
North and the South seven years later in
1987 I was separated from my family and
I walked across 800 miles on food to go
to Ethiopia feeding on wild fruits and
leaves of trees and dodging bullets
crossed unforgiving semi-arid zones of
southern Sudan when I arrived in
Ethiopia I was told about this idea of
education I was not alone there were
over 16,000 unaccompanied minors in that
refugee camp who all came from southern
Sudan we were as the joint schools and
the schools we joined were not regular
schools I began learning letters under a
tree and I had to write on the dirt I
did not have a pen or a pencil or an
exercise book and so where thousands of
fellow country men who were joining
schools at the camera children I was
wondering what all this about education
was going to be but there was one thing
that bothers me it was the fact that I
was separated from my family I did not
understand about the the so-called
education at that time but a few months
later the UNHCR received the children
and many other NGOs began to support the
education programs in the camp we began
receiving a few pencils and exercise
book two people had to break a pencil
and and break an exercise book and we
began to enjoy the idea of education
first of all I did not even wanted to go
to school before these pencils and
exercise book came all I wanted to do
was go back to Southern Sudan but
surprisingly one day one of my friend
came back from a school and told me that
they were distributing biscuits in
addition to pencils so I went the next
day to get my biscuit and they did not
continue disputing biscuit now a few
years later three years in Ethiopia
there was another political turmoil and
we had to be kicked out at the refugee
camps in Ethiopia and we tripped across
the semi-arid zone of southern Sudan to
go to Kenya in 1992 I arrived in Kenya
and at that point I had witnessed in
southern Sudan the massacres that were
taking place the bombings of the
villages the killings of innocent people
so nobody you know I need no one at that
time to tell me of what was happening in
my country and my teachers lectures to
us that the reason our country is at war
first of all lack of education many
people in southern Sudan were denied
proper education and and many people in
southern Sudan were being manipulated by
policies of the war and the
propagandists and that if we have to
change Sudan we must accept the idea of
being educated I joined my schools again
in Kakuma in 1993 the Kenyans government
again provided teachers the UNHCR funded
our education and was a free school
except that I had to sit under a tree
sits on a stone or on a log and then my
teacher did not have a chalkboard or a
chocks itself to write on but we had
hopes again donation drops in relief
supplies dropped into the camp and we we
began to build our own schools and we
had permanent structures right now there
are 21 primary schools in Kakuma where I
grew up and three secondary school but
then it was in Kakuma where I realized
that education was not only an important
things in anyone's life but it was a
necessity for anyone who want to leave a
better life growing up in southern Sudan
and in the refugee camp then being told
always that the problem in my country
was Arabs against Africans there was
Muslims against the Christians and that
the north did not like the South was
something that I would have not come to
understand had I not been educated I
started reading newspapers and reading
articles to fully understand what was
the problem in my country and as I speak
to you if you tell me that the problem
in Sudan or in the south and the North
was Islamic or Christian against Muslim
I will say no because religion had never
been the problem in the south
no I will not accept that today if you
tell me that the problems in the sub was
because southern Sudanese did not like
the idea of even Arabic culture to be
taught in the sub I will say no the
problem was the small elites who want to
control the country wanting to stuck
into that power and whoever was opposes
to that was attacked
that is why my people became the victims
that is why we lost almost three million
in southern Sudan for over 21 years in
Kakuma I joined drama groups and became
a youth leader through education I
became a peer counselor and I would even
speak to my colleagues who themselves
had gone through the same atrocities
that I went through and when I explained
just the same story that we had before
someone would say oh if you can bear
with this I can bear with it as well how
would I have learned to reek answer
someone or to keep cancelling to someone
if it were not because of education it
happened that my flight again to America
was scheduled on September 11 2001 I was
leaving behind everything and I knew
that I did not know much about the
United States but there was only one
reason I trusted to go to a new country
the fact that I would speak the language
of someone that I don't know and if I
know how to speak English why do I fear
where would you land that if you're not
educated today I have come to notice
that we as the people of the world have
much in common than we even know
we can only be able to land that if we
spread education to everyone in any
corner of the world
and Valentino I you not only talk the
talk you walk the walk every penny from
your book and and also Dave Eggers
revenues they are all going to a school
that you are building in Sudan and and I
believe that that's still still you're
looking for a little additional funding
hint hint
and as one of those many unfunded needs
and education all over all over the
world well I said before that my
original flight was on September 11 I
was stranded in Nairobi for two and a
half weeks and I alighted in New York at
the JFK on September 25th and found out
that due to the new security arrangement
my flight had been changed again and I
was sent to a new place as opposed to my
- to being sent to San Jose in
California which I really wanted so much
because I had looked at the map and knew
that San Jose was not cold and I was
worried and I was worried that if I get
sent to Fargo it would be difficult for
me to begin a new living so in in I
began wondering but I was told that I
was going to Atlanta and I confirmed
that Atlanta was in the United States so
there was not a problem
I arrived in Atlanta and began doing
speaking engagement at local schools and
colleges and it was in Atlanta actually
where I met with Angelina
two weeks after I arrived wasn't that
funny
and what I did was that I realized
through my speaking engagement that I
was not going to be able to tell much
about my own life and I wanted so much
to help people understand what was
happening in my country and that
continued to happen in there for today
so I began to to seek a writer to help
me write my biography and I was
introduced to Dave Eggers and we met we
became friend we went to my first and be
a game in Atlanta where I enjoyed
everything but the cheerleaders there
was a new thing to me and we after the
book came out I decided that I wanted to
be able to give back that I wanted to be
able to make a child in Southern Sudan
and everywhere smiles and through that
smiles I will feel the fulfillment and I
will continue to forgive my wars past so
we committed the proceeds from the book
into building second schools in southern
Sudan I visited southern Sudan in
December 2003 and reunited with my
family and I went back two month ago and
we going to build a second school we'll
begin with the first one in November and
aim to build five school how I'm going
to build this school is going to be
different I go and meet with the
grassroot people and hoping that once I
begin the school I will be able to see
the difference I have made within two or
three years and then I go on from there
and one measure of the extraordinary
unmet need for education in southern
Sudan is that a girl in southern Sudan
is actually more likely to die in
childbirth then she is to become
literate maternal mortality lifetime
risk is greater than the probability of
becoming literate for a girl in southern
Sudan which is just a measure of the
challenges we face you know the unmet
challenges I think may be one of the
things that Americans perhaps don't
appreciate and you alluded to it and
Minister Ottmar did as well is the
attitudes toward education that in this
country we're used to our kids saying Oh
school let's go to school again you know
we think of you know kids not being
thrilled with that idea and on the other
hand if you travel around the world you
know that at this very moment they're
gonna be thousands of kids who are
crying right now because they have to
drop out of school because they can't
afford a school uniform or a school fee
or because it's too far away or or some
other obstacle
I wondered if let me just throw this up
this sense of just desperate desire to
get education is that's something that
you have seen I you know across the
board in in the places that you've been
we'd all say yesterday absolutely I
think it is a oh it's always right took
three kids to school this morning that
weren't that excited I am it's it's
always very uh you know it is it's a
very emotional thing especially when you
ask them what they want to be I think we
all discover that you know I think you
ask a lot of kids here what they want to
be and forgive you
actress you cannot know the most noble
professions but you ask them there and
and they all want to be great things
because they all want to do great things
for their countries and and you know I
hear you speak and I just think you know
we we often hear about your country
today we hear every something-something
today going on with Darfur Southern
Sudan still and so
and aren't we lucky that we have men
like you that have had an education that
are going to do great things and help
deal with these two great challenges and
help make it better and I think that is
understanding that is what we're really
all talking about is is it and you are
that great example so in my country we
find that people are more and more eager
to get in education for instance we have
an institution to lend money to
university students our ami aim is to
multiply this is to Tucson by 66 times
more students this time more amount of
money to lend to them
primary school at secondary school are
the necessity for children under five to
go to the school we will find obstacles
we need to build more schools to connect
the schools to enlarge the payroll of
teachers to improve the education the
level of education of the of the
teachers I will need to provide many
families with subsidies for them to send
their children to school and we need to
provide the children with nutrition
although we have improve a lot in
nutrition we also we also need to
provide nutrition two to three million
poor children in our country this is a
challenge for that to come in here but
there is one big problem what a big
obstacle against education in our
country illicit drugs therefore we need
to defeat illicit drugs because illicit
drugs the drug dealers the terrorist
groups online forest and the rural
families that they have to
grow illicit drugs that they cannot send
their children to schools therefore we
need to defeat illicit drugs and we need
to replace the income for the families
let me refer to one very important
toilet here we are plenty of tunnels and
I want to invite them to consider this
option for my country this program is
called forest ranger families Colombia
has 51% of its territory still in jungle
drug dealers and of like families to cut
at the jungle down and to replay the
trees for illicit drugs what we are
doing is to sign contracts with families
for them to abandon illicit drugs for
them to keep the jungle to supervise a
jungle recovery and we pray to every
family two thousand dollars per year we
began this project three years ago and
we and so far we have completed 15,000
families but what we need one hundred
and eighty thousand families this
program is under the supervision of
United Nation it is very effective as a
tool against the global warming and of
course in a country with a long
tradition of violence
it'll necessary to teach values we
Colombians need to learn how to live in
community how to solve problems Italy to
teach values for us to learn values is
very important in Colombia and to
intervene in education it is very
important the presence in our country of
NGOs we need NGOs at every level of
education and then receive payments from
the government and of course they need
donors to help them get the funds
on IDI just to follow up on the point
you raised about subsidies for example
you know I think that we intuitively
tend to think of expanding education by
building schools but there has been a
lot of research to show that one can
also increase education very
cost-effectively in many places by
having school lunches for example as an
inducement to parents to send kids to
school 17 cents a day by the World Food
Program or if you build latrines for
girls in schools then you dramatically
increase the number of girls who stay in
school you deworm kids that may be the
most cost effective way of all of
increasing education we're just about
out of time but Angie I just like to ask
you for those people who are you know
interested in pursuing this issue then
how can they find out more about unmet
needs that they might want to find out
more about well we're all working
together to I think that is that is the
thing we've discussed that for children
and conflicts as you as you mentioned
there are so many different ways we need
their very special circumstances whether
it be that these are children that have
to work them have to work or that these
are children that don't have food and we
have to figure out ways with school
lunches so there are many and there are
many different programs many different
countries and many different types of
needs security concerns specific
concerns for girls so so the need is is
all of us there's not one specific ass
so there are there is a kind of menu
from some of us I know from the
education partnership for children
conflict we're working together and and
we're working in many different
countries there is a menu that's been
kind of put together we've helped to
weave what we've tried to do is look for
people already doing great work trying
to put together to explain to you here's
what they're doing here's who they could
help here's what country and really try
to lay it out as clearly as possible and
say trust us we've done the research we
know these are good people so please try
to get involved but all of us here I'm
sure have different websites in
different places you could go but but
that is certainly one of them and and
please you please finish it
sure actually I was coming back to that
first question very briefly we're
officially out of time actually in
Afghanistan we don't have the demand
for education the challenge there is how
to meet that demand it's primarily about
supplies teachers particularly female
teachers is a key constraint there we
have to train new generation of female
teachers we have to build more schools I
mean only 40 percent of the 9,000
schools in Afghanistan have buildings
and and still the parents are sending
their children to schools that are
literally in open spaces and the issue
of improving quality through developing
a value-based and irrelevant curriculum
is there so indeed what we are trying to
do in Afghanistan is actually to honesty
the generosity of our international
partners as well as the Afghans
themselves and and translate that
generosity into meeting the critical
needs of of of Education in in their
country well I think that one of the
reasons the impediments why people don't
act more on this issue is the sense that
it's huge and hopeless and just so vast
that it's hard to make a difference but
it like to leave you with that Hawaiian
proverb about or the Hawaiian story of
the man who comes across the kid on the
beach and all these starfish have washed
up on the beach and the kid is throwing
the starfish back and the man says to
the kid what's the point of this you can
never throw all of them back it makes no
difference and the kid says well sure
makes a difference to that one and
indeed it you know it really does make a
difference to all those individuals out
there and so I'd like you to please join
me in thanking the extraordinary
panelists not only for their
contributions today but for their great
work on this issue thank you
ladies and gentlemen the plenary session
is now concluded